Netflix has finally released footage of
their upcoming avatar The Last Airbender
series and with that I've discovered
something Netflix has biomechanically
bred the cast to look exactly like their
animated counterparts these people were
already Picture Perfect castings
visually so much so that I almost
couldn't believe it but then you hear
these clips and oh my God these kids
sound like the characters too Kara
sounds like qara if the world is going
to have any chance it's going to need a
like finding some with the hilariously
unique head shape of animated Saka is a
feet within itself but someone that also
simultaneously sounds like him too right
there goes the savior of the world nope
nuh you aren't fooling me Netflix I'm on
to you when your biolab is uncovered I
will be the first to say told youself